Hello and welcome to another episode of
What's Up, Prof?
Hello, Martin. Good day, Walter.
Hi. I hope you're not as miserable as
this fellow looks.
We look a much maybe a little bit better
on the outside, but maybe that's how
sometimes we feel on the inside.
I don't know. Why does he look so
miserable? What's wrong with him?
I think he's in the church.
I hope he's AI.
Is he AI generated? I'm sure he is,
right? Cuz I don't want to
implicate anybody in
in his unhappiness. You see the the
eyes, the you can see the tiredness in
the eyes. He has had sleepless nights
over this issue, I'm pretty sure. For
sure.
I don't know.
We can feel
related. Yes, yes, yes. We we we have a
connection.
Let's open with a word of prayer.
Our heavenly Father,
we are here
as
we want to
uplift everybody.
And we cannot do that if you are not
helping us. This is your cause. This is
your church, and this is
everything to do with your ministry. So,
we want only what you want us to say and
to teach. So, help us in this discussion
in Jesus' name. Amen.
Amen.
Martin,
we're probably going to be
I don't know. Ridiculed from some
places.
Public enemy number one. Yeah.
Shall we leave the church? The cries out
there are
becoming more and more numerous.
People are leaving the ranks.
And they have their reasons.
And uh
others are coming into the ranks. Mhm.
Uh for exact opposite reasons. So, this
is all very strange what is happening in
the churches, right? Yeah.
And if you do not conform to the exact
thinking of some of the individuals,
then you are doomed to go straight to
hell, not to pass go, and not to collect
200 bucks.
And no get out of jail free ticket. No
get out of jail free ticket either,
yeah.
So, let's talk about the church.
Shall we leave the church because there
is obviously
a confusion of ideas within the church?
Let's say there is apostasy within the
church.
Or let's say there is apostasy according
to the perceptions of some.
Mhm.
And fanaticism according to the
perception of others, and never the
twain shall meet.
Yeah.
And
uh
who decides what is a tare and what is
wheat?
There are perceived people that think
they are the ones that should do that.
Oh, there are people within the church
that have a degree in disseminating
between tares and wheat. I thought the
Bible said
that the angels were going to do that
weeding in the end.
And tie some of them into bundles and
some into others, right? Yeah.
Because maybe something looks like a
weed initially,
but actually is not a weed. True. And
particularly in the Middle East, where
the weeds looked very similar to the
grain.
And it was only possible to distinguish
between the varieties once they were
ripe.
So, what if one is a growth in progress,
for example?
We've mentioned it quite a few times.
It's like Aaron.
Yes, Aaron.
Aaron, what's the same? If you had to
choose,
is he should he be part of the church
when Moses came down from the mountain?
Would you vote for him for general
conference while he was
lying about the golden calf? Definitely
not. Definitely not, right? Yeah, and
it jumped out of the fire.
There it was.
All right. Okay.
So, shall we leave the church? And that,
of course, implies
who is the church? And that's a very
important question because that, I
think, is one of the main reasons why
you've got all these different voices
shouting differently, using the spirit
of prophecy. And everybody uses it,
right?
All right. So, who is the church?
By the way, Martin, does the Bible say
and the spirit and the bride say come?
Uh
definitely. So, What's the bride doing
there? Isn't the spirit enough? Mhm.
Paul, when he was on the way to
Damascus,
the spirit
intervened. Christ appeared to him.
He was blinded
because he first had to become blind
before he could see.
Yeah. And then he was put in connection
with the church. But the church was
perfect.
You remember?
That church with towards the way he was
sent.
can be perfect cuz they were arguing
with God. Mhm. No, no, no. Do you do you
have you any idea who this guy is that's
coming into the church over here?
He's a chosen vessel of mine.
Or what about the eunuch? Mhm.
He was studying
Isaiah, right? And he wanted to know who
who is this this
individual or this thing that is
happening here in the book of Isaiah.
Who's it speaking about?
And uh an angel could have told him. The
spirit could have led him in the right
direction, but Philip had to go. Mhm. He
was sent there.
And Philip was actually supplied with a
turbo
Yeah. to catch up with him.
He ran. And then he was
supplied with a super turbo to
suddenly be gone in another town, right?
Yeah.
So, the Lord took a lot of trouble
to send a representative from his
church.
Or let's use another example.
Peter
has this notion that any Gentile is
unclean.
And to even eat with him is a is a
terrible, terrible sin.
So, three times he hears, "Do not say
that that which God has made clean is
unclean." And immediately he went to eat
pork.
Is that right? No. No. Three men were
outside, all of them unclean.
Don't associate with them. Do you know
what the first thing he did was?
He invited them in to stay there. Yeah.
So, that they could plan whatever was
the trip.
And then he went with them, but he knew
he's going to be in trouble. So, he took
six people with him as witnesses.
You see?
The church, it's still the it's still in
the body. Yes. Now, number one, they
must have been very upset.
Because if they stayed there the night,
for example, then six Gentiles were
sleeping in their beds.
Beds had to be fumigated or something.
probably their whole house burned down.
Correct. Then he went, and they received
the Gentiles, Cornelius and his family.
The Holy Spirit, just as they had
received it.
And the interesting thing is, when he
got back,
he immediately got into trouble. Yeah.
All right. But then he explained the
situation.
And the church accepted it with
gladness.
Until a little while later,
when they they decided to switch to
reverse gear.
And eventually Paul even had to
reprimand Peter, remember?
Mhm. Okay.
But the fact of the matter, this
perfect, non-perfect, arguing,
altercating church
was the church. So, what is the church
and why is it the church? Is it a body?
Is it the spirit and the bride say come
or is it Who needs the bride?
It would be so much easier just to
follow the spirit and get rid of this
bride because look this guy's bad
sleepless nights
because of the bride, right?
So, let's have a look at this thing.
So, let's ask a question, who is God's
church?
Uh God's church ex- consists of those
who are all perfect
and never put a foot wrong.
They are the absolute perfect
representatives and that's the church,
right?
Well,
the truth is no.
The truth is no. Okay, so let's look at
it.
Acts 7:36.
He, that's God,
brought them out after that he had
showed wonders and signs in the land of
Egypt and in the Red Sea and in the
wilderness 40 years.
They were a very cohesive bunch those 40
years, right? All on the same page,
right?
the time. Yes, no, right? Just read the
history. The history is very important
to us.
Okay, so God used a representative and
that's Moses to bring the children out.
And it says here in verse 37, "This is
that Moses which said unto the children
of Israel,
"A prophet shall the Lord your God raise
up unto you of your brethren like unto
me, him shall you hear."
So, Moses was actually a representative
of a higher
power.
And this is of course a reference here
to Jesus Christ.
Now, Moses being a type of Christ uh had
to go through some experiences of
rejection.
And so, the antitype, Christ himself,
had to go through a period of rejection.
They had to listen to Moses because he
had God's word,
but they refused to listen to that.
And so, in the similar fashion, they
have to believe later on to Jesus.
Uh but
the same opposition will take place
there.
Uh is this opposition within the church?
Still today, yes.
Okay. Now, verse 38 is very insightful.
This is he that was in the church in the
wilderness with the angel
which spake to him in the Mount Sinai
and with our fathers who received the
lively oracles to give unto us.
The lively oracles to give unto us,
that's the gospel message of salvation.
So, Moses received from the angel of the
Lord
the oracles of God.
So, within this group, they had the
instructions of how to attain to eternal
life.
Now, that instruction was of course only
for them, right?
That's where the problem came in. They
thought it was
thought it was only for them. No, it was
for dissemination.
Preach it.
Live it. Be an example.
So, this is the battle. So, who is God's
church? God's church
consists of that body
perfect or not
that has the oracles of God.
That has the information. The oracles
are perfect.
Yes, that's God's word. It contains
everything. And the oracles that Moses
received was the Pentateuch.
And that is the first five books of
Moses.
And together with those five books
he also wrote the book of Job which
tells you of some various mindsets
within the church that weren't always in
harmony with that word.
Ex- very very good book. It It's amazing
that like you just mentioned, that
explains a quite a bit of the different
views inside of the church.
Correct. So, he wrote the first five
books, he wrote the book of Job that
tells about the conflicts and the
mindsets.
And then he also wrote a few Psalms.
So, they had a songbook. They had a
hymnbook.
They had the word of God. And those
first five books in type
present the entire plan of salvation.
Anything else that had to come there
after by the voice of the prophets that
was added
to the oracles had to be in harmony with
the first five books.
So, anything that a prophet said there
after was called the testimony.
And the testimony had to be in harmony
with the Torah, which is the law, which
contained also the 10 Commandments.
That was the word of God. And that was
God's church. Here is my information,
preach it to the world, live it.
Total disaster for 40 years.
But nevertheless, in spite of the
disaster
many accepted the truth and were saved.
They looked
and they lived.
All right.
Now, when the Jewish nation rejected the
Messiah
was the Messiah clearly portrayed in the
first five books of the Bible?
Definitely. It was it like you said, in
type. They lived it every day in the
tabernacle.
He was the lamb.
The innocent lamb that was to be slain
and he was the priest.
He was both of it. He was the mediator
of a of a covenant.
So, there was the plan of salvation.
Everything was depicted in the sanctuary
as to how the plan of salvation would
work.
Now, you can take that and you can make
it a ritual
and say, "Okay, I'm following this
ritual, therefore I am saved."
Or you have to study into it and see
what the real issue is and ask for a new
heart so that you can comply. Yes, and
then say, "I do this to honor the one
that has done all this for me." Okay.
So, if I decided not to do anything that
it said, but I was
an Israelite
then I was walking with them, I could be
one of the mixed multitude or whatever.
I knew they had the truth, I just didn't
live it.
I even
could do the sacrifices and all of the
things that had to be done, but
the heart was not Okay. So, it was a
perfect uh
test. Shall we put it that way?
To see if they will walk in this way or
not.
And this took place within the ranks of
the church.
Now, could you run away from this
church? Yeah, if you wanted to.
Yeah, if you wanted to, but then you
didn't have the oracles, right?
Exactly, then you out in the wilderness.
Cuz God gave the oracles to the church.
You actually out in darkness if you
didn't stay with the truth. Correct. So,
let's just go a little bit further and
say, "When the Jewish nation rejected
the Messiah, that was clearly depicted
in the Pentateuch
who then became the custodians of the
oracles of God?" That's the question.
Who now has to represent what the
oracles, the word of God, has to say?
Well, let's read it. Acts 13:46. Then
Paul and Barnabas waxed bold.
He's speaking to the Jews. He's speaking
to the physical Israelites.
And said, "It was necessary that the
word of God
should first have been spoken to you,
but seeing you put it from you and judge
yourselves unworthy of everlasting life,
lo, we turn to the Gentiles."
Is there a switch here?
Yes.
Why? Because they rejected the oracles.
So, they had the oracles, but they
rejected it completely. So, what's the
oracles worth at that time? No, it was
just a ritual. It was a tradition. And
they sat with a tradition, but they
didn't have the oracles anymore. They
had traditionalized it, if we can say
that.
So, let's go to Revelation 12:6
and it tells us who took over.
And the woman, now remember in the Bible
a woman is a church.
Yeah.
Fled into the wilderness.
Now, were the children of Israel in the
wilderness?
Yes. So, we have a similar experience.
So, the message that harbored the
salvation
issue
was with the Israelites. Now, they
rejected it and God said, "We turn to
the Gentiles. We give it to them."
And the church
was then born. Uh-huh. They had the word
of God, the same one that the Israelites
had,
but recognized that the central figure
was the Messiah, and that the type had
been met in the antitype.
So, they were the ones that could
explain and carry the oracles of God to
the world.
Yeah. And those that wanted to just
stick to the tradition
and forget the substance,
they were just left behind.
Uh they could still be grafted in if
they came to their senses, but as a
nation,
it was over. Yeah. It was taken from
them and given to the Gentiles, right?
And this woman, this church, was also
persecuted.
Just like they persecuted and killed the
prophets,
so they persecuted this church. They
threw them into jail. They had them
beaten.
And the more they did that, the more
they grew. Yeah.
Okay. So, first they got the church to
persecute them. They sent Paul
to go and persecute them, who at that
time was called Saul,
and said, "Go and persecute these
people." And he became one of them.
Yeah. That's a big problem. He changed.
All right. So, this terrible sect
that he persecuted
actually caught him in the net. Yeah, he
joined. And he became a sectarian, and
he was proud of it.
Yeah. Okay.
So, this is the church. And this woman
was then persecuted not only with from
within,
but she was also persecuted from the
powers, the political powers, the Romans
and Nero
uh used them as as tortures, right? And
burned them in the Colosseum.
So, she fled into the wilderness.
She had to separate herself from the
ideologies
that were round about.
Mhm.
Either those based on tradition or those
based on paganism. Separate yourself.
So, she went off into the wilderness
where God had prepared a place for her
with that he should feed her. Now, feed
her. What is she feeding on? The
oracles. The oracles. She must study the
word and understand the oracles. How
long was this process taking place?
1,260
days.
The modern that is the 1,260
day or year period of papal supremacy.
Yeah.
Where again,
tradition had taken the place of the
oracles.
That's it.
The oracles were hidden.
They were hidden in a foreign language.
Mhm. Latin. Nobody read it. And even if
they could, they couldn't read it. They
wouldn't understand the language and
they couldn't read in the second place.
Okay.
But God fed her. The word didn't
disappear.
So, this church was now the one that had
the oracles in the wilderness, and she
was being fed by them. Yeah.
Now, what happens after the 1,260
which if we remember our prophetic
picture was from 538 when the papacy
assumed political clout
to 1798 when she lost her political
clout.
Now, she was just a woman basing her
teachings on tradition.
Yeah. Like the Jews had.
But she was no longer a political power.
So, this woman had the oracles and was
fed by them
during that 1,260
day period or year period, which ended
in 1798.
Okay. What happened thereafter?
So, we read in Revelation chapter 12
what happened. And I heard a loud voice
saying in heaven, "Now is come salvation
and strength and the kingdom of our God
and the power of his Christ, for the
accuser of our brethren is cast down who
accused them before God
before our God day and night." So,
Christ is the center.
Mhm. And they have the oracles.
And they overcame him, the the enemy,
Yeah.
by the blood of the lamb.
That's the plan of salvation.
And by the word of their testimony.
So, now this is the word of God
Yeah. that consists of the Pentateuch
plus what the prophets had added.
Yeah.
And they loved not their lives unto
death.
Therefore, rejoice ye heavens and ye
that dwell in them. Woe to the
inhabitants of the earth and of the sea.
So, that's the nations around.
For the devil has come down unto you
having great wrath because he knows that
he has but a short time.
The short time that he has is from the
time of Christ till the close of
probation. Yes.
We're now almost at the 2,000 year
period for that event, right?
And when the dragon saw that he was cast
into the earth,
he persecuted the woman which brought
forth the man child.
So, he persecuted the church
that had Christ as its center. Yeah. He
was using the antichrist power to do
this. Yes.
The 1,260 years. So, what happened to
this woman that now had realized that
the oracles of God were actually wrapped
up in the Messiah.
So, the woman were given two wings of a
great eagle that she might fly into the
wilderness. There we have that same
picture. She goes into the wilderness
just like the children of Israel. They
were taken out of Egypt,
Yeah. taken to the wilderness. So,
you're taken out of the world and the
thinking of the world and brought into
harmony with the church.
Yes. In the wilderness is where God can
talk to you and get you Even Moses had
to go into the wilderness for 40 years
to get God to make his mind uh in line
with him. Uh many things happen in the
wilderness. For example, your diet is
changed.
And you could long for the flesh pots of
Egypt. All kinds of little things which
we're not going to talk in great detail
about.
All right. And there she was nourished.
What was she nourished with? Probably
the oracles again.
With the oracles. Okay.
For how long? For time, times, and half
a time, which is exactly the same as the
1,260.
So, this church had the oracles, and she
was nourished by them for 1,260
days or years.
And she was clothed in sackcloth. It
wasn't easy.
Yeah. Is There's always persecution and
difficulty
if you have the oracles.
And the serpent, of course, wanted to
get at her. Yeah. All right. What
happened then?
So, what happened after the 1,260
days?
Well, we read in verse 17 that the
dragon was then wroth with the woman.
Obviously, she was doing something right
because he didn't like her.
And he went to make war with the remnant
of her seed. Okay. So, there's a remnant
that has to come out of her after the
1,260
days.
Uh-huh. That's Is that clear? It's very
clear. And it's very important to see
when it had to happen. All right.
Now, what is the attributes of this
remnant?
Mhm.
They keep the commandments of God.
They don't keep the commandments of the
world or traditions or natural law.
Yeah. They keep the commandments of God.
And they have the testimony of Jesus
Christ.
So, they had the oracles. Yeah.
And they were living up to what the
oracles was saying because the oracles
said, "You have to keep the commandments
of God."
And they have the testimony. We need to
know exactly what that
entails.
So,
chapter 14 verse 12 tells us
what these saints are actually doing.
So, here's the patience of the saints.
Here are they that keep the commandments
of God.
And have the faith of Jesus.
We need to know what the faith of Jesus
is.
Now, many would like to change that to
the faith in Jesus.
Yeah.
Not good enough. No. You have to have
the same faith that he had. Yes. You
have to believe what he believed. It is
very important. So, what must you study
in order to find that out? The oracles.
We're back to the oracles. All right.
So, these people must have the oracles.
They understand the centrality of
Christ.
Mhm. They study the Bible and they
believe just like Jesus believed. Did
Jesus believe the oracles?
Absolutely.
And they have the testimony.
So, if we go to Revelation 22 verse 14
and jump right to the end of the issue,
it tells us, "Blessed are they that do
his commandments, that they may have the
right unto the tree of life and may
enter in through the gates into the
city. So, obedience becomes a very
important part Yes. of this issue. Of
course, many don't like this verse, so
they use other renditions. Mhm. That's
it. They take away that part and becomes
washing washing machine, yes. Like the
Sinaiticus and the Vaticanus and those
documents, which I personally consider
as
belonging where they were found, in a
waste paper basket.
Many will disagree with me, but that's
their problem.
Okay, so have we got a summary here?
Yes. Also important
So,
do his commandments, like you just
mentioned.
There's a very it's important,
but it's also important always has to be
in the right sequence.
Okay.
So, after 1798, who has the oracles?
This church that was in the wilderness.
And they all live up to it, right?
Well, they live up to it in the
wilderness before. No.
All right, but those that are within
this group, that do his commandments,
will have the right to enter into the
gates into the city.
Okay. Now, we also have to we have to
mhm look at that because you can do
commandments on a works basis. That's
why I mean the sequence has to be
correct. Or on a faith basis. And the
only way that you can actually be in
harmony with the oracles if you if you
have the faith of Jesus. Yeah.
That's why you have two aspects there.
Keep the commandments, have the
testimony,
and keep the commandments, have the
faith of Jesus. That's
And then do the commandments.
Yes. From the right perspective. Okay,
we've got that.
That's why I say the sequence. The faith
comes first and then the outcome of the
commandments is secondary. You can't
keep the commandments to try and get
faith. All right, so now
did the oracles move basically from
the Israelites, the physical nation of
Israel, to the church in the wilderness?
Yes. And then was there a remnant after
that now had the oracles?
Yes.
Okay. Were any of those perfect along
the line? No. Okay.
So, we have to now finally ask the
question, what is the testimony? Mhm.
We're just sitting in background.
Getting a platform. All right.
Revelation 19:9, and he said unto me,
write, blessed are they which are called
unto the marriage supper of the lamb.
Would you want to be part of that? For
sure.
And he said unto me, these are the true
sayings of God. Mhm. What are we talking
about here? The oracles.
We're talking about the oracles.
And I fell at the feet to worship him.
So, he's speaking to the angel.
And uh he said unto me, the angel, see
thou do it not, I am thy thy fellow
servant and of thy brethren that have
the testimony of Jesus.
Worship God.
For the testimony of Jesus is the spirit
of prophecy.
So,
when a prophet speaks,
on whose behalf is he speaking? God's
behalf. He's speaking on behalf of God
and specifically on behalf of Jesus.
Yes. Because the testimony of Jesus is
the spirit of prophecy. There must be a
prophet
that is,
you know, receiving the testimony.
Now, this a remnant,
does it have the spirit of prophecy?
Yes. Yes, because it says over there,
that have the spirit of prophecy, and
what is it?
The It is the testimony of Jesus. So,
there must be the prophetic gift must be
in the remnant, right?
Okay.
So, let's have a look what the people or
the institutions
that were the harborers of the oracles
of God, in other words, they were the
church,
that had the information to give to
others. Was that the the job if you have
them?
It's no use keeping it to yourself.
No, it's no good putting it on a shelf
and no good saying, oh good, I found it,
I'm not going to share it.
No. You get into trouble. Yeah. It won't
suc- it won't succeed. Eventually, you
will
Correct. You receive them for nothing,
so you have to give them away for
nothing, right?
So, with this faith of Jesus, how was it
restored to the church?
Mhm.
So, in other words, that which Jesus
believed,
which is in the plan of salvation and
that is in his word, how did the church
respond to this? When the Israelites
came out of Egypt, were they in
darkness?
Total darkness.
What gave them light? The oracles. Uh
when they come out of paganism, Mhm.
were you in darkness? Yes, most
certainly. So, what gives you the light?
Same thing. And where did you find the
oracles? In the church.
Martin, you're being very irritating.
Sorry, but that is what it was. Because
out there you were looking for it and
there were other institutions calling
themselves churches that did not have
the oracles, so you didn't find it
there. Okay, so if you found that the
church was not perfect and was muttering
and wanted the flesh pots of Egypt and
wanted to choose leaders to take them
back to Egypt, would you look as
miserable as this guy? Well, eventually
you get to that portion that part
because in the beginning you don't know
that it's there. You think it's going to
be all honky-dory. All right. Okay,
let's have a look what happened to the
oracles.
The authority of the Bible.
The early church had the oracles.
And then they somehow
got lost in tradition again, right? God
had to do something about it. There was
always the voice, Yeah. like the
Waldenses
or the Albigensians
or some
portions, Celtic church, etc., that kept
the faith.
But basically it got lost again. It was
scattered. So, nobody really had the
oracles,
or they were very hidden somewhere. You
see, it's interesting
that during that part there were
oracles, but it was scattered. So, the
message could not go out Correct.
to where it's supposed to and the in the
strength that was supposed to go out. It
had to come
together again. All right, if the whole
world has to be warned,
and final decisions must be made, then
surely you need the oracles.
They come and
together.
All right, so let's have a look how this
unfolded.
It started with the morning star of the
Reformation, Wycliffe.
He again recognized the authority of the
Bible.
He actually translated the Bible,
but he didn't have the right
manuscripts.
But he did the best that he could. So,
he pointed back to the authority of the
Bible and not the authority of those
that claimed to be
the church, but didn't present the
oracles, rather traditions. Those that
actually
made themselves oracles. Correct.
And then the next step was in the 1400,
obedience to God rather than man.
There was
Jan Hus.
Now, he was uh one who had discovered
the writings of Wycliffe and took it a
step further.
What did they do to him?
They burned him. All right, they killed
him. What did they do to Wycliffe?
Nothing. They couldn't kill him. So,
after he was dead and buried for a
while, they dug him up, burned his
bones. Rather futile exercise.
I see they just carried a saint through
the streets there in Europe.
And uh the skeleton of the saint dressed
in a tabard. And I understand the heart
of the saint was in a bottle somewhere
in one church and the hands were in the
in some other churches for veneration.
You know, it really hasn't changed. I
mean, if you think about it, it's so
pagan, it's unbelievable.
You can then the then this the people
say that the African religions are
barbaric. It sounds but it's the same.
This is macabre and
more than 100,000 pilgrims went to to
witness this thing. But we're we're
getting off the subject. Let's rather go
back to this issue. All right, so what
is being discovered here? The faith of
Jesus.
Wycliffe
says back to the Bible.
Hus says, we better obey this rather
than man.
Uh 1517,
Martin Luther discovers the
righteousness of Christ and salvation by
grace. Ooh, big trouble.
Yeah, that's a thought.
Anathemas rolled out against this
hypocrisy and this heresy, right?
And then 1555,
freedom of conscience, Calvin. I don't
know whether he ever lived really up to
freedom of conscience because he also
persecuted people that didn't agree with
him.
But you see, But at least he put the
idea out there into the world.
He brought the oracle back to what it's
supposed to be.
must decide.
And then baptism by immersion
was the next one. So, that's what Jesus
represented. So, that had to become part
of the faith of of God's people, right?
So, here's a progressive
uh regaining of the knowledge.
Yeah.
So, almost like finding the word of God
again and going into it. And any one of
these
is actually the harbinger of the
Oracles.
Now, that didn't mean that there weren't
individuals that
realized that adult baptism was the
right thing to do, like the Anabaptists
that became that were there before 1650.
In the time of Martin Luther already.
Uh but
to get it to the point where it is
actually tolerated, frowned upon but
tolerated,
you had to get to this point. So, the
Baptists came up with an organized
structure
that recognized the Oracles and started
getting into harmony with some of its
issues.
The next point was 1705, and that is the
Lordship of Christ and obedience to him.
That's Wesley.
Now, he wasn't very popular. Yeah.
It's it's it's actually sad. Yeah.
Putting Christ back where he belongs
actually got him a lot of flak. Yes. And
they called them Methodists because oh,
so you think you've discovered a method
of salvation. Now, so we're mocking
them, right?
So, the word's actually a mockery.
And he said, back to the commandments.
Did he recognize the Sabbath in those
commandments?
No. Not
No, he didn't. But, at least he
recognized hey,
and did he get to the point where he
said, you know, your body is the temple
of
of the living God. You better, you know,
bring your life in harmony. Stop
drinking, stop doing this, stop doing
that. And that didn't make him very
popular, right? No.
And then
to 1844
you had the pre-millennial coming of
Christ
preached.
Yeah. Everybody was building the kingdom
here down on Earth.
Yeah.
And here comes the Millerite movement
and says, "No, excuse me. Sorry. Christ
is coming to set up the kingdom. The
kingdom is spiritual."
Didn't the Jews make that mistake as
well when they said, "We want an earthly
kingdom and we better get rid of this
Jesus or else our system will fail."
Yep.
It's Uh
Better that one man
dies
than our system goes to waste.
So, they had a great revival.
And most of those that were in the
revival were Millennialists. In other
words, they were going to build the
kingdom down here. And here comes the
Millerite movement and says, "That's not
biblical." He wasn't the first. And Hout
before him had also said
pre-millennialism. Christ is going to
come and set up the kingdom. That's what
the Oracle says.
And that's what Jesus proclaimed. So,
that's the faith of Jesus.
And uh they tortured him until he died,
right?
Okay.
So, this idea came back. So,
as we go through the time periods, the
Bible becomes important. You have to
obey God rather than man. You're saved
by the righteousness of Christ and
salvation is by grace. You have freedom
of conscience. You can decide, not the
church for you or the government for
you.
Baptism by immersion, you become a
member of the body of Christ by giving
your life to him, accepting the
teachings and demonstrating the death of
the old self and the resurrection into
the thinking pattern, the faith of
Jesus.
And then you realize that Jesus is the
Lord and you have to be obedient to him
not only with the spiritual laws but the
physical laws of health as well. That
was Wesley.
Then Christ is coming to set up the
kingdom and we have to be obedient to
him.
And then you have the Advent movement
from then onwards. Gathering all of
these philosophies together.
Getting the Oracles back.
Into a organized
Yes.
And proclaiming the three angels'
message.
Yeah. The time of his judgment has come.
Worship him who made the heavens, the
Earth, the springs of water.
Those churches that do not want to
accept this message become part of
Babylon. They have fallen.
And please don't accept the mark of the
beast. Don't accept a false
tradition-based religion based on a
pagan day of worship rather than God's
way. That's the three angels' messages.
So, who has the Oracles now, Martin? The
Advent movement. The Advent movement has
the Oracles. So, they must be the
church. Yeah.
So, the message is a universal message
of separation from apostasy.
It's always a call out.
Come out of Egypt. Abraham, get yourself
out of Haran.
Into the wilderness.
Okay?
Revelation 14:6, "And I saw another
angel flying in the midst of heaven
having the everlasting gospel." Is that
the Oracles? Yes.
To preach unto them that dwell on the
Earth. So, what What is the gospel? What
is the mystery
that entails the gospel?
It's Christ. He became a human being.
He took my sin upon him.
He died in my behalf. He became my high
priest and my mediator.
I have to come back into harmony with
him.
I have to keep the commandments and the
faith of Jesus. Believe what he
believed, the Oracles.
And he is coming to set up a kingdom
of which I want to be a part.
That's the gospel. Simple.
And then 18:4 says, "And I heard another
voice from heaven say, come out of her,
my people, that you be not partaker of
her sins." Now, sin is the transgression
of the law.
Yeah.
"And that you receive not of her
plagues." So, if you refuse to obey God,
you will receive plagues eventually.
Mhm.
That's the message of the remnant. Do
they have the Oracles? Are they
therefore God's church?
Yes.
Second Corinthians 6:17, "Wherefore come
out from amongst them and be separate,
says the Lord, and touch not the unclean
thing, and I will receive you." It's
always part of God's message to separate
yourself from the thinking patterns of
the world.
Mhm.
Right?
It's It's not rocket science.
No.
All right, Martin. So, let's have a look
at the remnant again.
They keep the commandments of God. Is
that biblical? Yes, for sure.
They have the testimony. Yeah, it's it's
part of the of the remnant.
of the remnant. So, they must have the
spirit of prophecy.
Yeah. There must be a prophetic gift in
them.
Mhm.
Uh did the Israelites receive a prophet?
Constantly. Okay.
But, they also have the faith of Jesus.
Mhm.
They must believe the Oracles.
And they arise after 1798.
Yes, that's very important. It says so
clearly in Revelation chapter 12, right?
After the 1,260-day
prophecy.
They must preach the three angels'
messages.
Mhm.
And it must be a worldwide movement.
Now, how important is that one? Okay, it
must be a worldwide because the the
first angel says they were preaching it
to every nation, tribe, and tongue in
the entire world.
All the people.
unit. So, it's a universal message.
All right. Ask yourself, who keeps the
Which church
says we must keep the commandments of
God and not tradition. Which church
claims to have the spirit of prophecy.
Which church arose after 1798
having incorporated everything that the
church in the wilderness had and put it
all into into the settings of the
Oracles.
Preaches the three angels' message and
is a worldwide movement. Only the
Seventh-day Adventist Church.
one that qualifies.
And that is
a movement, a church. It's a movement.
And they're perfect, right? No. No.
That's why this man looks so miserable.
The Oracles that they contain
or that is in there, that are perfect.
But, the people that have to keep to it
looks That's what the problem is. All
right.
Now, here's a quote from Selected
Messages. Now, Martin, people say, you
know, don't talk about the spirit of
prophecy. Don't talk about the writings
of L. N. G. White. She was a woman and
who wants to listen to a woman in the
first place?
Uh were there women that were prophets
in the Bible?
Many. Miriam was a prophet. What about
Hulda? Yeah. Mhm?
There's You know,
Deborah?
I'm sorry. Did uh
Barak want to go ahead without her? No.
He couldn't go ahead of him. That's a
typological story of the end, by the
way.
So, I'm not going to be apologetic about
this, because it's very biblical. It's
one of the requirements of being
qualifying as being the remnant church.
Okay. Now, if there's so much confusion
out there in the world,
wouldn't it be nice if God gave a little
bit of direction that was absolutely in
harmony with the word of God?
So, that when you study it in the word
of God, you actually find it there.
So, what does she say herself?
Men may get up scheme after scheme, and
the enemy will seek to seduce souls from
the truth, but all who believe that the
Lord has spoken through Sister White,
and has given her a message, will be
safe from the many delusions that will
come in these last days.
Now, either that is the biggest lot of
nonsense you've ever read in your life,
or it's true. One of the two.
And if it's true,
then you can't pick and choose which
ones of the messages that she gave you
want to. In other words, you have to
look at them, and you have to study
them. And then, when you have studied
them, you have to ask yourself the
question,
is this in harmony with the law and the
testimony of all the previous prophets?
Yes. So, you go to the word of God,
which is your final call. That's it. And
if you find it there,
uh you better listen.
So, if she says you shouldn't lust after
the flesh pots,
and you find it in Exodus that they
lusted after the flesh pots, and God was
not pleased with them, and send a
leanness into their soul, they lost
their discernment. That part you can
read in Psalms.
Yes. And if I say, "But I love the flesh
pots of Egypt, and I don't want to
listen to what she says," it means
you're not listening to what the Bible
has to say.
Unfortunately, many delusions will then
come. And many will leave the church
because they don't want to listen to
what is being said here, right? Or maybe
they even leave the church because they
misquote her and misuse her. Or quote
half.
Half. Can you quote half the Bible?
If you want to sustain something that
you want to say, and not what the Bible
says, yes. But that is the way the
danger lies. The whole Bible has to be
quoted. The whole spirit of prophecy has
to be used. Okay. Cuz so, could you
leave out Acts 8:37 if it doesn't suit
you? No. Yes, you leave it out in the
new translations. Of course, yes. If it
doesn't suit you, yes, you should leave
it out.
out, right? And the NIV, you just leave
it out, right? Okay. But I really want
the whole oracle of God. I don't want
snippet one. No. Okay. All right,
Martin.
That's the basics of the remnant.
Yeah.
So, let's go a little bit further.
Uh let's ask a question. What is the
condition of the remnant?
Well, luckily, the Bible tells us
exactly. All right.
Well, the parallel to the last
harborer of the oracles of God is
Laodicea, the last church on Earth.
That's important to re- to remember or
realize and when you read it, because
there's no
church after the Laodicean church.
No, that's it. This is the last one. So,
let's look at its condition.
And unto the angel of the church of the
Laodiceans write, "These things says the
Amen,
the faithful and true witness, the
beginning of the creation of God." So,
we're talking about Jesus and the faith
of Jesus.
And this church is the last
representative, and it has the oracles
of God. Now, let's look at its
conditions. I know your works.
You are neither hot nor cold.
I would that you were cold or hot.
You're fence sitters.
So, then, because thou art lukewarm, and
neither cold nor hot, I will spew thee
out of my mouth.
So, there's some spewing out that's
going to take place. Who is doing the
spewing out? God is doing the spewing
out. Am I the spewer? No. Are you the
spewer?
No. Are you separating the wheat from
the tares?
Definitely not. All right. Do they stay
there until the harvest?
Absolutely. Is the harvest taking place
already?
Yes.
Who's doing
the spewing? Not us. So, there's a
shaking.
For sure. Okay.
So, you're going to be spewing out if
you don't come into harmony with the
faith of Jesus, right?
Why? Because you say that I'm rich.
If you're rich, you you must have
something of value. What do they have?
The oracles.
We're back to the oracles. They have the
oracles of God.
And they are increased in goods. They
know what it's about. They suppose they
understand it.
And they have need of nothing.
No. So, they're in the same condition as
the Jews were.
We have it all together. We don't need
this nonsense now to come and interfere
with our earthly plans here.
And you know not that you are wretched,
you are miserable,
you are poor,
you are blind,
and you are naked.
So, Martin, they don't have the
righteousness of Christ.
That doesn't sound like a perfect
church, does it?
No, this is this is a pretty imperfect
church. They're wretched, they're
miserable.
They're actually poor.
But they say that they are rich. They do
have the oracles, but they don't live up
to them, so they're actually poor.
And uh they don't want to listen to the
testimony, because that takes them to
the oracles.
And that's the Old Testament. We don't
have to worry about that.
And they're blind, like Paul was. He had
to become blind before he could see.
And they are naked. This is the
condition of the church. So, is the
condition totally hopeless?
It depends on how you want to ask what
If it's hopeless if you don't react.
React. All right. Now, what must be done
in order to escape this hopelessness?
You have to apply what the oracles are
saying.
All right. Let's have a look at it, cuz
there must be a solution. Otherwise,
we're all lost. And it's important to
say this, because
unfortunately, a lot of people accuse us
of saying,
"You're a Laodicean church. You should
stay like this."
Or they say, "Get out." That's the other
one. But they say that they accuse us of
saying, "You have to stay in a Laodicean
state." Correct.
All right. So, what is the solution?
I counsel thee to buy from me gold tried
in the fire. That is character. Yeah.
You have to get the character that
Christ wants you to have.
So, that you may become rich.
And I want you to put on the robe of
righteousness of Christ, so that you
stop thinking that you are the bee's
knees, perfect within yourself. I'm
rich.
I know the truth, and all these
knuckleheads down around me are
pathetic. I'm leaving them, because I'm
rich.
Or even I'm doing everything that is
right, and they don't do it, so
So, that you may be clothed. Will there
be people at the wedding feast that come
with their own garment?
Oh, for sure.
Uh what's going to happen to them? Out
into darkness. Out to dark.
Where there's gnashing of teeth, right?
And that the shame of thy nakedness do
not appear, and anoint thine eyes with
eye salve. They're blind.
Now, what can give you the eye salve? He
God. The oracles.
The oracles. He says, "Come and buy from
me that eye." That he can give you the
eye salve. So, that you may see.
All right. As many as I love, does he
love them?
Oh, yeah.
He loves them in their pathetic state.
Did he love the Israelites in their
pathetic state?
I rebuke and chasten.
Be zealous, therefore, and repent.
I knock at the door. If you hear my
voice, open. I will come in, and I will
sup with you. If he sups with you, he's
your friend.
I just wanted to ask something about the
rebuke.
Through How does God rebuke you?
He puts you into the furnace of
affliction. And he gave And he comes
through the church He comes with the
oracles. Yes. So, it's not saying there,
"And your brothers will rebuke and
chasten you." So, if he speaks the
testimony of Jesus,
is that his word?
Yes. Is it Is it the oracle? For sure.
It's his word, right?
But it has to be in harmony with what
has been given as a package, which is
the word of God, which is this book
here. It's called the Holy Bible.
Okay?
And he is doing the rebuking and the
chastening. So, there's some overcoming.
Yeah.
And I will grant to sit with me in my
throne, even as I also overcame and sat
down with my father in his throne. So,
if you have an ear,
then please listen to what the Spirit is
telling you. The Spirit is going to
teach you.
And he does this within the crucible,
which is called the church.
This is the condition of the last
church. That's why the man over there on
the backdrop looks so miserable.
And just to make it clear,
it is our goal to, with the help of
Christ not be in that state. All right.
The leaders, were they always perfect?
Definitely not. Were the leaders in
Israel perfect? Was Caiaphas perfect?
No, right?
There's nobody. Not even Moses was
perfect. Even he had a problem
when he Did Luther chase Carlstadt away?
Cuz he recognized the Sabbath and wanted
to get rid of the idols, right?
Uh did Calvin
see to it that certain people were
eradicated that didn't agree with him?
Okay, so none of them were really
perfect, right?
It depends on how you define perfect.
Yes. All right. So, how does God adjust
the situation within his church?
Let's go to Isaiah. The sinners in Zion
are afraid. Fearfulness has surprised
the hypocrites. Or the hypocrites in the
church. They're in Zion. They're in
God's church.
Who among us shall dwell with the
devouring fire? Who amongst us shall
dwell with everlasting burnings?
He that walketh righteously, speaketh
uprightly, despiseth the gain of
oppression, shaketh his hands from
holding of bribes, stops his ears from
hearing of blood, and shutteth his eyes
from seeing evil.
In other words, he doesn't have a
television in his house.
That's true. Or a newspaper coming in.
You don't have a television, Martin.
He shall dwell on high. His place of
defense shall be the munitions of rocks.
Bread shall be given him. That is also
the word of God. And his water shall be
sure.
So, Martin,
there is a sifting that takes place in
the crucible that is called God's
church. That's the point. How serious is
this?
Well, Ezekiel tells us how serious it
becomes.
He cried also in mine ears with a loud
voice, saying, "Cause them that have
charge over the city to draw near. Every
man with his destroying weapon in his
hand."
And behold, six men came from the way of
the higher gate, which lieth towards the
north. That's where the throne of God
is.
And every man a slaughter weapon in his
hand, and one man amongst them was
clothed with linen. So, the
righteousness of Christ.
With a writer's inkhorn by his side, and
they went in and stood beside the brazen
altar.
And the glory of the God of Israel was
gone up from the cherub where upon he
was to the threshold of the house. And
he called to the man clothed with linen,
which had the writer's inkhorn by his
side. So, here is an investigation
and a recording of what is actually
happening in your heart, right? So, who
is the
man with the inkhorn? Well, it's an
angel that has been sent and he's
commissioning what Christ has told him
to do. Go and record what each one is
doing. So, this is not a church member.
No, this is an angelic being.
Okay.
And the Lord said unto him,
unto this angel,
"Go through the city." That's Jerusalem.
But that's a symbol of the church. So,
we might as well read it. Go through the
church.
Through the midst of the church,
Jerusalem,
and set a mark upon the forehead of the
men
that have decided to leave the church
because of its Laodicean state.
Does it say that? No.
All right. Let's Let me read it then
again.
Try another one. I'll try reading it as
the article puts it.
Set a mark upon the forehead. In other
words,
thinking in harmony with the testimony
of Jesus.
Of the men that sigh and cry for all the
abomination that be done in the midst
thereof.
Sounds like this man. It sounds like
this man, then is Does that say, like
you just mentioned in the previous one
that wasn't the article, that this man
has to leave? No, it says they must sigh
and cry. Like he's been doing some
sighing and crying in the middle of the
night. And sighing crying, is that um
getting everybody out?
No, he's just sighing and crying.
And to the others he said in mine ear,
"Go ye after him through the city and
smite.
Let not your eyes spare, neither have
pity. Slay utterly old, young, both
maids, little children, women. But come
not near any man upon whom is the mark,
who has the testimony and the faith of
Jesus."
And begin at my sanctuary. So, who's
going to sort out the mess?
God and his angel. God is going to sort
it out. He's going to separate the wheat
from the tares.
I'm not a wheat tare separator.
It's God's job.
Then they began at the ancient men which
were before the house. And that's why I
just mentioned before asked the
question. This is
This is not a church member or a pastor
or any evangelist that's doing this.
No.
There are people that are sighing and
crying. Yes. And God will sort it out.
But this is right at the end.
Yeah.
Do we want to jump the gun and do this
for God because he's obviously in our
opinion not doing his job?
All right. Let's read Selected Messages,
book two. This is going to be quite a
Yeah. substantive discussion, but let's
Let's see where it leads us.
God is leading out a people.
He has chosen
a people. He has a chosen people, a
church on the earth whom he has made the
depositaries of his law. Do they have
the oracles?
Yes.
He has committed to them sacred trust
and eternal truth to be given to the
world.
He would reprove and correct them.
The message to the Laodiceans is
applicable to Seventh-day Adventists who
have had great light and have not walked
in the light.
Who? The Seventh-day Adventists.
It is those who have made great
profession but have not kept in step
with their leader that will be spewed
out of his mouth unless they repent.
The message to pronounce the Seventh-day
Adventist Church Babylon
and call the people of God out of her
does not come from any heavenly
messenger
or any human agent inspired by the
Spirit of God.
Is that a clear statement? It is a clear
statement, but unfortunately people
twist and
mutilate the whole thing because they
then go and say, "Yes, but the Adventist
That's why it was important that you
started off with what is the church. Who
is the church? Because they say, "Oh,
but that is only the members of the
church that constitute So, the temple is
the church. It's not this organization."
Yes. Unfortunately.
probation for the body ended in the time
of Jesus,
that's when that decision was made. And
if you decided not to accept the
Messiah, you suffered the consequences
of the destruction of Jerusalem.
Same will happen at the end. We're not
quite there yet. We're getting very
close.
Yeah. But this At this stage,
this organization
stands.
Feeble and naked and all of this stands.
There's a reason, and we'll get to that.
We'll get to that.
So, Christ has said of his people, "Ye
are the light of the world. We are the
Lord's denominated people. They have the
oracles." It's a denomination.
To proclaim the truths of heavenly
origin. The most solemn sacred work ever
given to mortals is the proclamation of
the first, second, and third angels'
messages to our world.
In our large cities, there should be
health institutes to care for the sick
and to teach the grand principles of
health reform. Were the Israelites under
a grand principle of health reform?
Yes. Did they moan?
Yes, the whole time. Okay.
I have a question.
There are people out there
that say that we, particularly me,
are dumb dogs that do not bark against
the evils in the church.
We don't mention the names.
And we have
often said that we don't mention the
names, but we address the principles.
Because the name's going to change. It's
going to change. Sooner or later, the
name's going to change. Are there people
in high positions in the church
hobnobbing in ecumenical councils Yes.
that say, "We do not preach or these
people do not preach the three angels'
messages."
They stick to just Jesus. But Jesus gave
an instruction to preach the three
angels' messages.
Now, should we now say that individual
who does that should be thrown out of
the church.
Is that my job or is that God's job?
That's God's job. Can I ask you another
question?
Is it only him or her
or are there hundreds like him? Yes.
all over. They are.
There's a right way and a wrong way to
deal with it. Yes. And the church has
very
clear
directions on how to deal with it. Okay,
now Martin
have we had confrontations or let's make
it very personal. Have I personally had
confrontations
with many of those with the mindset that
we are not going to do this. We're not
going to preach the three angels
messages.
Yeah.
Uh have I been hauled over the coals by
them? Yes. Have I been before councils?
Mhm. Have I written letters to them? To
all the leaders. publicly denouncing
what is happening. Mhm. Uh
my wife wrote a book dwelling in a
secret in the secret place
where the whole story is depicted
including one
of the letters that was written to every
leader within this organization.
It's out there. It's free. Get it from
our webpage. Read the book and see
whether we've been dumb dogs that
couldn't bark. Mhm.
Because we believe there's a right way
of doing it and a wrong way of doing it.
So you address the principle. Mhm.
Have we ever propagated an ecumenical
mindset in our ministry? No. Never.
Definitely not. Never.
Have we maintained that the the health
message is an important right arm of the
gospel? For sure. Do the
churches necessarily love us for it?
No. No,
not at all. No.
But they also reject the spirit of
prophecy on that issue, don't they?
Yeah. So they're not keeping to the
testimony which is the spirit of
prophecy.
So Martin
this is the very important thing.
They have to preach the three angels
messages. The fact that there are people
that don't want to because they have an
ecumenical mindset is their problem.
You know, it's interesting also we get
accused
especially you
that um
you
are totally against independent
ministries. Excuse me, I belong to an
independent ministry which is called
Clash of Minds.
Yeah. We are completely independent.
I be against that? I'm against
independent ministries
that say that you have to separate
yourself from the body because it has
become Babylon because I don't believe
it's biblical. I don't see and
definitely not Not according to the
quotes that we've just read. I don't
believe it.
So how far is this church going to go in
terms of apostasy? We read in selected
messages that the church may appear as
about to fall but it does not fall.
It's pretty plain.
It remains while the sinners in Zion
will be sifted out, the chaff separated
from the precious wheat. It's a terrible
ordeal but nevertheless it must take
place.
So Martin, there is going to be a
cleansing but God is going to do it. And
unfortunately, if you have maybe a
certain
mindset of how this is going to happen
don't be surprised when it's not turning
out exactly the way you thought.
Correct.
Because most of the time
people would say, okay, it's all the
people that don't go
along with everything, the more liberal
side of the view of all of this.
But if you are conservative and keep
into a lot of these things and you still
leave
you're in the same boat. You're in the
same boat. Now I have another question.
Uh we have an independent ministry. Mhm.
And we have an health institute.
The independent ministry is Clash of
Minds. The health institute is Verity
Center. We have them both, right?
So we irritate certain sectors of
society just by being that. Is anybody
ever baptized into Clash of Minds?
No. No. No, because that's that's not
what the oracles are telling you to do.
Are you an elder in the church?
Yes. I'm an ordained minister in the
church. I'm a Seventh-day Adventist.
Not because they're perfect but because
they have the oracles.
Have they given you in certain places,
well, basically, what's the difference
with being fired or banned from
speaking? It's about the same thing. I'm
banned in certain areas to speak.
But am I disfellowshipped or not in
regular standing? Absolutely not. I was
just the camp meeting speaker
at our great big conference here which
is a public venue. So you know, people
that want to say that I am singing
according to the tune of the leaders of
the church
I will sing according to the tune of the
leaders of the church if they are in
harmony with the Bible and the spirit of
prophecy. I'll sing the same tune.
If they are not I will address the
principles. Have we, for example, under
the recent epidemics that were taking
place
put our position very clear and that
that position was not necessarily in
harmony with what the body was doing?
Exactly.
We we made it very clear.
It's not supporting some
positions that the body has taken.
Correct. In fact, we made
numerous videos to say why it we have
the position that we took. Correct. But
we based it on the principles and not
the individuals.
Okay, so the church might appear to fall
but it does not.
Here's another quote from Manuscripts
129. The Lord has declared that the
history of the past shall be rehearsed
as we enter upon the closing work.
We surely are doing that, Martin.
Every truth
that he has given for these last days is
to be proclaimed to the world. Everyone.
Every pillar that has that he has
established is to be strengthened.
We cannot now step off the foundation
that God has established. We cannot now
enter a new organization for this would
mean apostasy from the truth. Is that a
clear statement? It's a very clear
statement and maybe
we will get to this but I want to
mention it already now. This is what I
meant with people like to use certain
portions of the of the spirit of
prophecy to make a statement.
So this was written in 1905 because
there were certain statements that we
will get to that were written earlier.
But you have to balance the two
to make sure that she did not say, oh,
let's separate.
I'm instructed to say to Seventh-day
Adventists the world over, God has
called us as a people
to be a peculiar treasure unto himself.
He has appointed that his church on
earth shall stand perfectly united in
the spirit and counsel of the Lord of
hosts to the end of time.
Uh if we are following the history of
Israel
there was always
discord within the ranks but the truth
was there. The oracles were there.
Now here's another one that comes from
Testimonies to Ministers.
Those who assert that the Seventh-day
Adventist churches constitute Babylon or
any part of Babylon.
Cuz some actually say now this level of
governance within the church is Babylon.
Yeah.
And this one maybe not and that one
certainly is and that one is not,
whatever.
No.
Any part of Babylon
may better stay at home.
Let them stop and consider what is the
message to be proclaimed at this time.
In place of working with divine agencies
to prepare a people to stand in the day
of the Lord
they've taken their stand with him who
is an accuser of the brethren who
accuses them before God day and night.
Don't accuse the brethren.
Weep and cry between the porch and the
altar because of the evil that is done
in Israel, the apostasy that is in its
ranks.
But that is the Lord's problem.
Don't run along with it. Set a better
example.
Did you run away or did you leave
because they told you not to preach
three angels messages in this church?
No. I told the individuals that told me
not to preach the three angels messages
that I didn't consider them Seventh-day
Adventists. They were very angry with
me. Were they leaders? Some of them were
deans of our largest universities in the
world and some of them were leaders from
the highest level in the church and they
told me I may not preach this, that and
the other and I told them that I must
obey God more than them. And if they
didn't believe it, that was their
problem and not my problem and I didn't
consider them Adventists and they were
very, very angry with me. And still you
stayed with the body.
I am still in the body because that's
where the oracles are. Where must I go?
And the shaking
and the sifting by the angel hasn't been
completed yet. He's certainly working at
it now because people are leaving in
drones, especially those that love the
flesh pots of Egypt, that don't like
certain statements Mhm. like some that
have left some of our big broadcasting
organizations lately and have said they
don't agree with this statement and that
statement because they don't study the
history of the children of Israel
and they believe that the testimony
is not from God but from another source
because it contradicts their little
habits. Mhm. Yes.
So, satanic agencies have been moved
from beneath
and they have inspired men to unite in a
confederacy of evil that they may
perplex, harass, and cause of the people
of God greatest distress.
The whole world is to be stirred with
enmity against Seventh-day Adventists,
Martin.
As a body.
Mhm. Because
they will not yield homage to the
papacy.
Do we have people in our ranks that say
the papacy has changed?
Yes.
Yes, they do. Have we shown over and
over that they have not changed? Just go
and have a look at the last two episodes
of what's a prophet we did.
So, who has the problem? Definitely not
us. They have the problem, right? And
the oracles in inside of the church is
still stating the same thing. So, that
there if there are people that want to
proclaim that or want to use a platform
saying that even if it's a
general conference leader
All right. it doesn't change the fact
that
I don't care who it is. There were union
leaders that wrote publicly against us
or me in particular
uh about this issue that Rome had
changed.
And uh I publicly rebuked him in a
letter. That's another one. You can go
and look it up on the web pages. It's
there.
There's an answer to a union president
that's in in the public domain.
And so, this enmity is going to be
against this church because we don't
honor the papacy and we don't honor
their Sunday institution.
And it's 90% power whether they like it
or not. It is the purpose of Satan to
cause them to be blotted from the earth
in order that his supremacy of the world
may not be disputed. One of the leaders
in this church told me that I may not
preach this. Yeah.
So, He actually said it's not part of
our fundamental beliefs. And I said,
"But the spirit of prophecy is part of
the fundamental beliefs, and therefore,
if she tells me that I must preach this
and the Bible tells me in Daniel chapter
7 that I must preach this and warn
against the little horn power, and
Revelation 13 tells me that this is the
problem at the end of time. If he
doesn't want to do that, that's his
problem. I would suggest to him that he
goes and joins another church because I
don't know what he does here and why
he's in this church.
If you don't want to keep to the oracles
and you don't want to accept it, then
I'm not going to leave because he
doesn't want to.
Oh, but I'm not going to spit him out.
No. If he stays in the church That's
fine. He stays even a dean of theology,
I don't care.
God will take care of him. Yep. Either
he'll change his mind
or
he will be spewed out, one of the two.
And
we'll we'll get to that also.
But if he's there
he will probably some will probably make
it right until the end.
But they not there in the right garment.
Maybe this. They'll they'll sit there in
the garment of their own righteousness.
Martin,
the main problem
that I see or the issue
is one of two. Mhm.
Those that want to appropriate the
righteousness of themselves, they're
perfect.
Yeah.
And everybody else is imperfect,
therefore we will separate. We are not
perfect.
And the other group is
do what thou wilt is the whole of the
law. We have these two highly liberal
thinking patterns.
Mhm.
And
one calling themselves
ultra-conservative
dressing themselves with their own
garment of righteousness. We're never
supposed to say that we are righteous.
We can claim it by faith, the
righteousness of Christ, but it is his
righteousness. Never mind.
And let him say it. So, just to
put that out there
we don't say that you will be saved in
your sin.
No.
And if we say that we have a fallen
nature, we are just reiterating what the
Bible says
and what the spirit of prophecy says.
And if we say that we are without sin,
we are liars and the truth is not within
us. We have a sinful nature. That
doesn't mean you have to listen to it
and sin.
Because we are buried with Christ
Exactly.
in baptism and resurrected with him. I
don't have to commit adultery because I
have a fallen nature.
For sure. I don't have to steal even if
I'm poor. Even though if Thomas Aquinas
gives me permission and the Pope in
Rerum Novarum gives me permission to
steal, that's breaking the commandments
of God and these people are basing their
theology on natural law. That's their
problem. I don't have to listen to it.
And I would rather stick to the oracles
of God. They are very plain. And I will
only
call the righteousness of Christ over me
perfect. That's the only perfection that
I can ever lay claim to.
So, let all be careful not to make an
outcry against the only people who are
fulfilling the description given in the
remnant people who keep the commandments
of God and have the faith in Jesus.
Martin, this is a very important
statement.
God has a distinct people, a church, on
earth second to none
but superior to all the facilities to
teach the truth, to vindicate the law of
God. My brother, if you are teaching
that the Seventh-day Adventist Church is
Babylon, you are wrong.
That's not me saying that, but I will
add my voice to it and say I agree.
Yeah. So, all of these barking
individuals who are barking at the
church while they have separated from
the church
have done so on their own volition.
I have actually written letters to some
of them
asking them to reconsider.
Martin, why should I suffer alone in
this church?
No, it's easy to get out. It's easy to
get out and say I want nothing to do
with it.
perfect because there's also some camp
meetings even ridicule that we don't
want to
tear the church apart and get and
separate from it. All right. Moses left
immediately when the when the children
of Israel apostatized, right? Mhm. I
wonder how
Can you name one that actually left? The
one through the years of the church that
actually
Nobody. Nobody. Nobody.
I do not doubt your sincerity or
honesty. I have written long letters at
different times to those who were
accusing the church of Seventh-day
Adventists of being Babylon. I have also
written long letters. You can go and
read them. They're in my wife's book.
You can get them from the web page.
They're not hidden somewhere in a
corner.
That they were not handling the truth.
You think individuals have prejudiced my
mind?
If I'm in this state, I'm
But this matter has been brought before
my mind in other cases where individuals
have claimed to have messages
for the Seventh-day Adventist Church
of a similar character and the word has
been given me
believe them not, I have not sent them
and yet they ran.
What are you going to do with that,
Martin?
Where did Where did they ran from? They
ran from the church. They've decided the
church consists of tares
and they're going to leave. They're
sitting outside barking their heads off.
It's amazing to me that those same
people believe themselves then to be the
perfect
harbingers of the truth and they know
how to even um
use utilize tithing.
They will be perfect in their use of
tithe.
Yeah.
Yes. Well, Martin,
who will take care of the issue in the
end? Well,
God will take care of his own work.
God has a church upon the earth who are
his chosen people who keep the
commandments. He is leading
not stray offshoots.
Now, if you are an independent ministry,
are you an offshoot? No. You can be.
Yeah, yes. But if you keep to the
oracles
that the church has and you still
supporting the body the body, baptizing
members into the body This is the
crucible.
Yeah. And you know what's interesting?
She writes that God will permit apostasy
to come into the church
so that you can have clear eyesight and
see, well, is this in harmony with the
oracles or is it not? And you make a
decision. It's the perfect crucible. So,
stay within this body.
It doesn't mean you have to partake of
the apostasy. Definitely. It's In In
fact, don't. No, don't. You don't even
have to join a denominational group
within the body
that is a boom boom bash church if you
think that that is not in harmony with
God's word.
Yeah.
You don't have to go and do that. You
don't have to climb on the bandwagon
that everybody else wants to climb onto.
Just weep between the porch and the
altar.
Ah, that's so important.
So, there's no need to doubt, to be
fearful that the work will not succeed.
God is at the head of the work. He will
set everything in order. If matters need
adjusting at the head of the work,
God will attend to that and
work to right every wrong. Martin.
We're going to have a general conference
meeting very soon.
A session.
Where the representatives from the whole
world can make certain choices.
You can use that body to set matters
straight. That is actually the That's
the place.
We've been saying this for 2 years.
If
Okay. If you have something to say, come
say it there.
it there.
So, let us have faith that God is going
to carry this noble ship which bears the
people of God safely into port.
When you think that the work is in
danger, Mhm.
and I believe that some of these people
really believe that the work is in
danger, just like I believe sometimes.
Maybe it's important to say We don't
disagree with them being agitated with
the apostasy in the church. Of course,
we are also. Yes. Lord
stand at the wheel. That's what you must
pray.
Yeah.
Carry us through the perplexity. Bring
us safely into port.
Have we not reason to believe that the
Lord will bring us through triumphantly?
You cannot with your finite minds
understand the working of all the
providences of God. Let God take care of
his own work.
Now, is there order and organization in
this church, or is this the spirit
leading and we don't need the bride?
That's very important because that's
what what most voices now that say that
the church has become apostate tells
you. There doesn't need to be an
organization because we're going to be
in any case uh church uh home churches
in the end. Okay.
Let none entertain the thought that we
can dispense with organization.
There are so many that shout against the
general conference.
And the committees of the general
conference.
Does the committee of the general
conference have the right to decide for
me uh what I should do? No. No.
No.
No. It doesn't have the right to do so.
Can I agree with some of the things they
say and disagree with others? Yes. Yes,
I certainly can. Whose choice is that?
Mine. Mine. May they coerce my
conscience?
No. And if they have tried to coerce my
conscience in the past, may I ignore
them?
Yes. All right. We go even further than
that. Have I ignored them?
Yes. Certainly. Certainly, I have
ignored them.
All right.
It has cost us much study and many
prayers for wisdom that we know God has
answered to erect the structure, which
is the church, right?
It has been built up by his direction
through much sacrifice and conflict. Let
none of our brethren be so deceived as
to attempt to tear it down.
For you will thus bring in a condition
of things that you do not dream of. In
the name of the Lord, I declare to you
that it is to stand strengthened,
established, and settled. It's not going
to go away. It's going to be sifted.
Yeah, yeah.
At God's command, go forward. We
advanced when the difficulties to be
surmounted made the advance seem
impossible.
We know how much it has cost to work out
God's plans in the past,
which have made us a people what we are.
Then let everyone be exceedingly careful
not to unsettle minds in regard to those
things that God has ordained for our
prosperity
and success in advancing his cause.
Hands off the church.
Hands off the apostasy in the church? Of
course, stay away from the apostasy in
the church. Talk about it? Yes. Be
uh
not happy about it? Yes. But don't
dismantle the church.
When I look at what some of the leaders
are doing, especially in Europe,
Mhm.
or in some parts of North America, or
anywhere else in the world, I'm
appalled.
I'm appalled.
But I'm not going to leave.
No, God is going to do the sifting.
So, the people of God, have they lost
confidence in this church? Let's be very
careful about this issue. Yes, because
this is important. This quote is here to
show that there was a time when Ellen
White was really not very happy with
what was going on. Correct. Especially
at higher levels, right?
Yes.
It is working upon wrong principles that
has brought the cause of God into its
present embarrassment.
This was written in 1901.
The people have lost confidence in those
who have the management of the work.
Yet, we hear that the voice of the
conference is the voice of God. Every
time I have heard this, I have thought
it was almost blasphemy.
Didn't we just say that? Yeah. That it
could be blasphemy what some people in
high positions are saying.
Every time I've heard that,
I was
on the point of thinking this is
blasphemy.
The voice of the conference ought to be
the voice of God, but it is not because
some in connection with it are not men
of faith and prayer. They are not men of
elevated principle. There is not a
seeking of God with the whole heart.
There is not a realization of the
terrible responsibility that rests upon
those in this institution to mold and
fashion minds after the divine
similitude. So, at that time, there were
leaders that were not acting in harmony
with the principles of God.
They were doing everything against what
the oracles actually were telling them.
Okay. Is it possible that we have
similar leaders, not all of them, but
similar ones today? For sure. For sure.
Okay.
This is just telling me
that those individuals
will lead in the wrong direction, but it
is not telling me that I must follow
them because they are the leaders.
Definitely not. All right. Now, that was
in 1901.
Let's jump a little bit further. This
was 1909.
At times, when a small group of men
entrusted with the general management of
the work have in the name of the general
conference sought to carry out unwise
plans to restrict God's work,
I have said that I could no longer
regard the voice of the general
conference represented by these few men
as the voice of God.
But, now comes the big butt, right?
This is not saying that the decisions of
a general conference composed of an
assembly of duly appointed
representative men from all parts of the
field should not be respected.
Is that coming up very soon? It's now,
in July. In July.
God has ordained that the
representatives of his church from all
parts of the earth, when assembled in a
general conference, shall have
authority.
In spite of people that have done
contrary to your conscience.
Yeah.
You cannot condemn the body
because it is at this level
that decisions become binding. That's
it. And maybe just to mention, maybe
it's important to mention that the most
of the gripes that people have with the
church
has not been done at this level. No,
it's not been done at the level. It's
been done by a committee somewhere.
And if you do not agree with that
committee, that's your perfect right.
They haven't got the authority to
dictate doctrine.
So, this is where the authority lies, in
the whole church making a decision. And
this is the beauty of the Seventh-day
Adventist Church.
We do not have a pope,
and we do not have a synod.
We have a general conference assembly of
representatives from the entire world
where decisions are made. Is it possible
that even at that level, Martin,
mistakes can come into the ranks, or are
they infallible? No, it's not
infallible. And I'm I'm sure God will
protect the main oracles, but sometimes
on something lesser, there might be some
Let's take an example of the early
church.
They had a general conference meeting.
Yeah.
Where they had to decide whether the
Gentiles were to be subjected to the
rules of Judaism. Yeah.
And
they made a decision, no.
Not. Mhm.
Did they live up to it?
No.
Right after that, there was already
problems. So, things can go wrong,
right? Yeah. Did the leaders sometimes
make decisions which were contrary to
sound principles?
Yes. Didn't they send Paul and tell him
to mingle as though he was still part of
the old system?
Yep, and he actually took Timothy and
did all kinds of things, and did they
make mistakes?
Yes, Peter Paul had to rebuke Peter.
Just bear in mind in case you think that
we're dealing with with absolute
perfection here.
So, the error that some are in danger of
committing is in giving to the mind and
judgment of one man or a small group of
men
the full measure of authority and
influence that God has invested in his
church
in the judgment and voice of the general
conference assembled to plan for
prosperity and advancement of his work.
Now, what if some of the leaders
say, "We disagree with that individual
or that individual because they are
preaching, let's say, a health message
contrary to our views."
Must we then obey what that leader at
high level is saying or must we go and
check in the oracles?
You go to the oracles and you've got the
spirit of prophecy and we've just read
and if that guy, doesn't matter where he
is in in authority there, is
contradicting it you ignore him.
You ignore him.
And if you had to have a discussion with
him face-to-face, you could tell him, "I
do not agree with you. I will not do
what you are saying because I believe
your idea is way off the mark."
Thank you very much. Have you got the
right to say that?
Okay. So, Martin, this is how it works.
And by the way, the things that we are
mentioning are they happening? Yes. Are
they saying that individual who is
preaching a health message is not
welcome?
Definitely. Well, that individual might
be very welcome in our ranks.
So, God has invested his church with
special authority and power which no one
can be justified in disregarding and
despising.
For he who does this despises the voice
of God.
Acts of the Apostles.
So, Martin, let's just summarize.
According to the scripture
there are two classes in the church who
will not partake of the wedding feast.
The one group is those that do not have
oil. They don't have
the Holy Spirit's working in their lives
to bring them in harmony with the
oracles.
Matthew 25:10, "And while they went to
buy
the bridegroom came and they that were
ready went in with him to the marriage
and the door was shut."
Afterwards came also the other virgins,
so they belong to the church.
Saying, "Lord, Lord, open to us." And he
answered and said, "Verily, I say unto
you, I know you not."
"Watch therefore, for you know neither
the day nor the hour with wherein the
Son of man cometh."
So, Martin, there are those within the
church
that know the truth. They're virgins.
They have access to everything, the
oracles of God, the testimony of Jesus,
which is the spirit of prophecy plus the
Torah.
They have it all
but they don't apply it to their lives.
They won't be there. They won't make it.
And then there are those that have their
own garment
that have decided that they are holy and
the rest is so unholy that they will
separate themselves from them. So,
they've separated from the church.
Exactly, just like Moses ran for his
life when they apostatized against God's
word, right? No, he never did. No, he
stood
Matthew 22
and from verse 11, "When the king came
in to see the guests
he saw there a man which had not on a
wedding garment." He had his own
righteousness on. He had declared
himself righteous. This guy wasn't He
did not take the mark of the beast. He
kept the commandments. Yes. He preached
to millions or hundreds of people.
everyone the church was Babylon, "Get up
because you have to be like me, holy."
"And he said unto him, 'Friend'"
Didn't he say that to Judas as well?
Was Judas saved? No, unfortunately not.
"How camest thou in hither, not having a
wedding garment?"
And he was speechless. Didn't know what
to say.
"Then said the king to the servants,
'Bind him hand and foot and take him
away and cast him into outer darkness.
There will be weeping and gnashing of
teeth, for many are called but few are
chosen.'"
Martin, be very careful
how you touch the apple of the Lord's
eye, which is his church.
Absolutely.
So, Martin
when I have stated in the past that we
should have glue
and stay within the body
that means you stay within the body that
has the oracles of God
that has the law and the testimony
and has the spirit of prophecy. You stay
in that body.
That sounds biblical to me.
Until the shaking
until God spews out of the mouth and
there is a remnant of a remnant that
brings the loud cry to the world.
Does it mean because you have glue that
you approve of all the apostasy that's
taking place? For sure not. No.
Does it mean you have to go along and
listen to certain leaders in position of
authority when they are speaking
contrary to the spirit of prophecy and
the word of God?
No. No, I don't have to listen to them.
I refuse to listen to them. Am I being
rebellious if I don't listen to them?
According to them, yes, but according to
the oracles, no. No. Do some of them ban
me? Yes.
So do I still go and speak in the area?
Yeah. Yes, because who are they to tell
me that I may not preach in this word?
Did the disciples, after they were
warned not to preach in that name, go
and preach in that name?
Yes. Yes, so in the same way I can
ignore them.
thrown in jail because of it? Yes. Was
Was I held before authorities because of
it?
Did God dig them out? Yes.
So, that's the way it goes.
And
Martin,
do I love this church? Would you think I
love this church? I think so,
definitely. Do you think I look like
that guy sometimes with the rings under
my eyes because of this church?
Well, I think we look like that now.
I think so.
I think we love the church and we love
the members of the church as well. Yes,
that one man said,
you know, "Christ is easy to love, the
church is not so easy to love."
Well, even Paul
lists all the difficult things.
"Ah, the brethren."
Yes, they're not so easy to love, but
the Lord loves them.
Okay, Martin, let me give another
example.
If your children are not all in the
faith
do you hate those that are not in the
faith?
You cannot. Or are you wearing your
knees out because of them?
That's how God feels. That's how God
feels.
That's how we feel. That's how I feel.
And uh
are all the leaders in high levels part
of the apostasy?
No, I've spoken to many of them. They're
not part of the apostasy. They're also
weeping.
Weeping, not sorting it out themselves.
All right. Now, here's another question.
Nicodemus
and Joseph of Arimathea
did they make huge whoop-de-doos in the
Sanhedrin? Or were they largely quiet
while they watched the proceedings?
They were largely quiet.
Uh
did the Sanhedrin actually try to
keep them away from important decisions?
Yes.
Uh were they
were they lost because they were largely
quiet? No. Was there a time when they
got up and spoke?
Yes, then they
they star shown bright at that time in
the way that was total darkness. So, I
want to say to all those who accuse,
stop.
In the name of the Lord stop.
Start praying.
Pray. God will adjust this church. This
church is going through to the kingdom.
It's the last one. It's Laodicea. I know
its condition.
And
I know that it has the oracles of God.
Therefore, I will wait for him to do the
shaking. And by his grace, not because
of any virtue of my own
I want to be part of the loud cry.
And that is where the rubber meets the
road
and not
in the church
militant.
It reaches its pinnacle in the church
triumphant.
Let's pray.
Heavenly Father
you have a body through whom you are
working. You have
handed to them the oracles of God.
It is a sad state of affairs
that probably the majority doesn't
adhere to it.
It doesn't make the oracles null and
void.
So, help us to stick to the law and to
the testimony, to keep the commandments
of God and the faith of Jesus, to keep
the commandments of God and the
testimony of Jesus, which is the spirit
of prophecy.
That is my prayer for everyone.
And I pray that many, many will accept
this truth
and will come into the ranks to replace
those that you in your providence will
shake out. A painful experience because
it might be those very close to us.
And if we do not watch and
take note, it might be us. So, help us,
Lord, to stand
is our prayer in Jesus' name. Amen.
Amen.